right now paleontologists discover a new
species of dinosaur every week and it's
no wonder dinosaurs dominated the planet
for 135 million years but they didn't
start out on top the first dinosaurs
emerge around 230 million years ago
during the Triassic period back then
earth looked very different instead of
seven continents there was just one
Pangaea even early dinosaurs were
nothing like those Hollywood giants
eeeyah raptor possibly the first true
dinosaur was puny especially compared to
top predators of the day like some of
the giant rasuu Kean's over the next 30
million years new species of dinosaurs
and amphibians developed along with the
first mammals life was flourishing then
201 million years ago everything changed
Pangaea began to tear apart the shifting
tectonic plates about volcanic eruptions
which over tens of thousands of years
tripled the amount of greenhouse gases
in the atmosphere and warmed the planet
by 3 to 4 degrees Celsius it vanquished
at least 30 percent of all life in the
process but for some reason maybe luck
or some helpful adaptation the dinosaurs
sailed on through to the dawn of the
Jurassic period and over the next 135
million years they continue to spread
diversify and evolve into some familiar
faces for example the first
Tyrannosaurus sprouted up sometime
around 170 million years ago but don't
get your hopes up
these guys are no t-rex the real
sovereign of the era was the Allosaurus
it dined on sauropods with its meat
cleaver teeth meanwhile Pangaea
continued to pull apart
by 145 million years ago had began to
resemble what we see today forming
isolated pockets while dinosaurs were
increasingly different it was the heyday
of dinosaur diversity and a new period
the Cretaceous in Argentina giants like
to tag Titan the biggest dinosaur on
record turned up around 100 million
years ago but the most frightening of
all appeared in the western US around 68
million years ago t-rex the largest
carnivore in history on its own it was a
formidable predator but it turns out the
t-rex likely hunted in packs and where
t-rex did not roam other pack hunters
filled the niche in Asia the small yet
cunning Velociraptor roamed it was a bad
time to be a mammal and then 66 million
years ago the Chicxulub asteroid wiped
out all the dinosaurs well almost all of
them one group remained their
descendants might be sitting outside
your window right now Birds that's right
modern birds are dinosaurs
turns out the legacy of these titans
today is well dinner this video was made
in large part thanks to Steve Barsotti
and the information in his new book the
rise and fall of the dinosaurs what
interesting dinosaur facts do you want
to know about let us know in the
comments